meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
mit dem Vorspiel auf dem Bildschirm
eröffnet das Zweite Deutsche Fernsehen
sein
[Musik]
Abendprogramm Deutschland im Jahr
2063 das Zweite Deutsche Fernsehen
feiert seinen 100 Geburtstag und wetten
dass auch hier endlich die Zukunft
Einzug gehalten hat denn nach nur einem
Jahrhundert und knapp 30 000 Folgen von
Bares für rares wird auf dem lärchenberg
zum ersten Mal eine Frau als Intendantin
die Geschicke lenken Glückwunsch Karten
ausgedruckt auf Papier das gibt es nur
noch beim ZDF kam bestimmt per
Einschreiben oder wie das hieß Liebe
Intendantin alles Gute zum neuen Job ich
hoffe sie lassen den lärchenberg jetzt
nicht umbenennen in
lärchenenberg Männer so lustig was kann
ich dafür dass hier vor mir keine Frau
einen wichtigen Posten übernehmen wollte
Verzeihung nicht wichtig mein Posten ist
sehr wichtig ohne mich würden die
Verträge hier reihenweise im Altpapier
landen weil mein Chef wieder ein paar
Schluck zu viel egal wer sind sie jetzt
die Sekretärin des Intendanten und sie
ich bin die
Intendantin ja klar und ich bin die
Bundeskanzlerin
was denn jetzt hier so lustig sie sagt
sie ist der
Intendant lassen Sie mich raten sie
sind die
[Musik]
Sekretär heute show history oh man 60
Jahre Frauen im
ZDF die Zeiten sind halt vorbei in denen
Frauen im ZDF nur Anträge fotokopieren
dürfen was hier nur und alles ist das
auch nicht ich meine die ansagerinnen da
ist ein ganzer Job komplett in
Frauenhand seitenweise lernen die Texte
auswendig und was für welche meine Damen
und Herren wir begrüßen Sie herzlich zum
heutigen Programm wir wünschen Ihnen für
die nun folgende Sendung viel Vergnügen
gegen 23 Uhr ist das Programm des
zweiten deutschen Fernsehens beendet
diese Damen sind das Gesicht unseres
Senders hübsch niveauoll anständig
erleben Sie ein hoch auf die Monarchie
die Herren der Herzen und wen
horizontal und dann schau es doch einmal
was sie mit ihrer Coch daheim so alles
anstellen können wo kommt das denn jetzt
her was meint die was ich mit meiner
Couch anstellen soll
egal ich meine die 60er waren doch viel
mehr
Studentenproteste Woodstock die Pille
entschuldigung ich muss jetzt hier mal
reingrätschen also bis beim ZDF
irgendwas von Summer of Love und
sexueller Befreiung
ankommt das
dauert aber keine Sorge in den 70ern
lockert sich der Weib hier endlich und
wir haben jetzt Sendungen wie wünscht
dir was ja hier eine 17-Jährige
präsentiert ihrer Mutter ein
[Musik]
Outfit erste Transparenzoffensive des
ZDF was hat die denn an ist
unanständig meine Güte hast du noch nie
Brüste gesehen hier ich zeig dir noch
mal welche sag mal das hältst du jetzt
hier wirklich für die große Befreiung
lass uns mal dem Teenagermädchen mal
eine durchsichtige Bluse anziehen das
ist ein Brüller meine Güte das sind
nämlich diese innovativen showmomente
auf die kommen einfach nur
Männer ja okay ja ja könnte sein dass da
jetzt ein männlicher Praktikant den B ha
versteckt hat dieser Thomas
wahrscheinlich moment mal Thomas
Gottschalk ja
du musstest Mutti versprechen dass du
hochgeschlossen kommst gell ganz genau
ja das und das ist auch Strickstrumpf
wir haben uns geküsst wir haben uns
geliebt war schon etwas verspannt oh
Gott das ist auch furchbar wenn man ohne
Brille kein BH mehr aufkriegt ich traue
mich gar nicht dir die Blumen zu geben
weil das macht immer noch hätte kam
Nebel mehr gegrabbelt wäre sie
vielleicht noch da na gut das ist euer
zukunftsproblem jedenfalls man muss ja
froh sein wenn Frauen hier in den 70ern
in ZDF Shows überhaupt Aufmerksamkeit
kriegen ja also wenn du nicht die
halbnackte Deko sein willst dann bist du
na ja die Assistentin das schmückende
Beiwerk so eine Beate halt also be ist
ein ganz apartes Wesen das nichts
ungerner tut als sich in der
Öffentlichkeit irgendwie in Vordergrund
zu dren Beate die hält blumenstrau ich
will mich gar nicht über Männer aufregen
ich will über die wahnsinnsfrauen hier
sprechen die erste Sportstudio
Moderatorin Caren Thomas guten den meine
Damen und Herren zu Hause und hier im
Studio dass die in diese Männerdomäne
eindringt das war blitzschnell eine
riesen Nachricht ganz besonders schnell
war die Zeitung wer trotzdem heute zu
einer Veranstaltung gehen möchte und
keine Zeit hat uns zuzusehen der kann
sich bereits jetzt vor der Sendung eine
große deutsche Sonntagszeitung kaufen in
der können Sie dann auch nachlesen wie
ich heute Abend sein werde der Autor hat
also geschrieben dass ich also unsicher
wirkte und dass auch meine sportlich
journalistischen Fähigkeiten wohl nicht
ganz ausreichten dem hat sie es gegeben
zum Glück was die Frau sich für einen
Mist anhören muss
ja
Frauen und Sport du willst nicht wissen
was los war als im ZDF 2018 Claudia
Neumann als erste Frau bei der
Männerfußball WM kommentiert hat und 5
Jahre später immer noch als sie als
erste Frau das Champions League Finale
kommentiert
hat wieso was war warte mal hast du hast
du gerade gesagt die erste wmkmentatorin
kommt
2018 na ja zumindest waren wir schneller
als die
ARD wir hat so viele
erreicht wir waren Pionierin in im ZDF
nicht nur im Sportbereich ich bin noch
nie in meinem ganzen Leben es gab auch
bisher im erst keine Anlass dazu so viel
fotografiert ausgefragt interviewt
worden wie in den letzten drei
Wochen ich muss sagen dass ich es
eigentlich ein bisschen merkwürdig finde
weil für mich ist die Tatsache dass eine
Frau Nachrichten vorträgt und das
einigermaßen glaubwürdig macht im Grunde
eine selbstbeständlichkeit und Wiebke
Brun war ja erst der Anfang hier
Ingeborg Wurster guten Abend und
willkommen zum heute journal die erste
Frau die das heute journal
moderiert rate mal wann D die nächste
Frau als hauptmoderatorin rin durfte
2001 Marietta Slomka guten Abend
herzlich willkommen zum heutejournal ja
sorry jetzt wollt den Frauen jetzt das
übel nehmen dass die zwischendurch auch
mal ein bisschen Spaß haben wollen ich
habe gar kein Problem damit den Jungs
ihren Schwanzvergleich zu überlassen
weniger Arbeit mehr
Sex ist gerade nachrichtenmäßig eh
nichts los
Moment die
80er Aufrüstung ternobyl die Grünen
bringen diesen ominösen Feminismus in
den Bundestag ja okay das aber sowas
verunsichert die Männer doch auch die
sind halt sensibel ja die sehen sich
nach so und das ZDF das schenkt eben
Frieden und Freude bisschen heile Welt
Orte an denen die Dinge noch ihre
Ordnung haben und die Geschlechter ihren
Platz die Schwarzwaldklinik z.B aber es
gehört sich doch nicht dass eine Frau
die Initiative
[Musik]
ergrei aus Liebe ist alles erlaubt so
jetzt guck mal Schwester Christa die
wusste wie man es macht als Frau sich
schön reichen Chefarzt Angeln also da
gibt's auch Ärztin aber also wenn ihr
mich fragt das sind alles angespannte
überarbeiteteippen dann lieber beat
trumchef die ist so
erfrischend sonst noch jemand eine
kleine
Erfrischung ah schön entspannt auf dem
Schiff um die Welt schippern und ich
meine Frauen haben auf dem Traumschiff
ja alle
Möglichkeiten Frauen finden in unserer
Gesellschaft allmählich den Platz der
ihnen
zusteht eines Tages wird auch ein Schiff
für die Deutschland von einer jungen
schönen Kapitänin geführt werden jung
schön nicht eventuell sogar kompetent
aber das ist egal hauptsache nicht alt
und
hässlich aber für Sie Frau Intendantin
ist das ja wahrscheinlich schon ein
alter Hut wie viele
kapitäninnen hatte das Traumschiff denn
bis
heute das Traumschiff fährt zwar seit
Jahrzehnten mit Biomethan aber Kapitän
ist immer noch Florian
Silbereisen hat gesagt er hört erst auf
wenn der welke die heuteh abgibt seid
doch froh dass es im ZF überhaupt so
legendäre Frauenrollen gibt wirklich und
ich habe noch nicht mal mit den ganzen
Müttern angefangen Gott was wir hier im
ZDF an Müttern haben so Vera Drombusch
in diese Drombusch hann Lore Wichert von
nebenan und II Schumann in ich heirate
eine Familie übrigens Frau
Feministin die betreibt sogar ihre
eigene boutike als alleinerziehende
Mutter und dann hat der Werner die
geheiratet obwohl die die Kinder hat ein
Wahnsinn
ja hallo hast du dir die Serie mal zu
Ende angeguckt II hat ihren Job
aufgegeben weil es ihren Mann in eine
komplette Sinnkrise gestürzt hat dass er
nicht Alleinverdiener ist hat sich so
verändert s sie diesen Job hat ich bin
doch wirklich nicht altmodisch von mir
aus können Frauen arbeiten auch wenn Sie
Erfolg haben auch wenn Sie Erfolg haben
aber sie muss doch nicht unbedingt mehr
verdienen als du wir brauchen das Geld
gar nicht allein Verdiener ey das kann
sich auch heute überhaupt keiner mehr
leisten bei solchen Stories da könnte
ich wirklich verzweifeln aber oh das
hätte W rombusch natürlich nicht gewollt
die ist nie verzweifelt die hatte immer
genug durchhaltol für die ganze Nation
Wunder gibt es nicht es sei denn wir
schaffen sie selbst man zeigt keine
Stärke man hat sie Mutter komm das
schaffen wir auch noch eine Sache haben
wir immerhin geschafft seit
1988 endlich eine Sendung von Frauen für
Frauen abgesegnet von Männern das ZDF
Frauen
[Musik]
Magazin und jetzt alle mon
Lisa mon
Lis du weißt schon dass das die Flippers
sind und nicht mL mona lisa das ZDF
Gesellschaftsmagazin mit feministischem
Profil kann sein ja ich guck das ehrlich
gesagt nicht die habenmer so relevant
them Abtreibung so Gewalt in der
Partnerschaft oder so Pärchen die so
friiges Zeug
praktizieren der Vater betreut die
Hausaufgaben und macht viel im Haushalt
wäscht und putzt für die Familie während
seine Frau den behördenwust erledigt
dafür muss sich roswiita schwendke vor
den Verwandten
verteidigen dann dann hinterher dann was
hast du für ein Waschlappen weil er zu
Hause geholfen hat Hausarbeit der Mann
wäscht und put ja wie gesagt das ein
Waschlappen also ich gucke lieber
Fernsehgarten da ist wenigstens Stimmung
in der
Buder nein bitte
[Applaus]
nicht ich habe jetzt einen traumhaften
Ausflug vor auf einen tollen Käsemarkt
oben unter Schulter Schulter vorne vorne
Schulter Schulter Winkel Winkel oben
unten Schulter Schulter vorne vorne
Schulter Schulter Wink Schulter Schulter
winke winke also das gefällt mir so und
immer noch in Frauenhand der
Fernsehgarten was habt ihr denn ich
verstehe das nicht
ah okay wahrscheinlich haben die Kerle
einfach keinen Bock sontags früh
aufzustehen aber egal eine mega Sendung
frag mag ich fast so gerne wie die
ganzen Krimis Polizistin das ist auch
bei Frauen gerade trendjob da brauchst
du in erster Linie zwei Qualifikationen
sehr betroffen
gucken und Namen mit Alliteration Bella
Block rosa rot gundola Gause guten Tag
verehrte Zuschauer nee die seriös aber
Hauptsache feurige Frau
FEG die Frauen hätten hier im ZDF viel
mehr anzünden müssen um was zu erreichen
was denn anzünden ihre BHs das ist
vielleicht zu deiner Zeit noch cool
spätestens bei blond am Freitag ist das
nur noch eine stallvorlage für
tentenwitze ich meine Barbara wenn du
dein BH verbrennen würdest dann müsste
die Feuerwehr ja vier Tage löschen ne
also wisst ihr was wenn ich das alles
höre kriege ich auch Lust meinen
Büstenhalter macht einfach mal halblang
wir haben ja einiges geschafft wir haben
beim ZDF 2023 ein ausgeglichenes
Geschlechterverhältnis eine 5050 beszte
Geschäftsleitung und und hier na bringt
jeden männlichen Talkshow pavianhaufen
locker zum Schweigen also
meistens un nicht
noch die wurde längst von einer KI
ersetzt aber wie sagte eine langjährige
ZDF Philosophin lebe geht weiter eben
lebe geht
weiter brauch wir noch me hat eine
Aufführung mit der theaterag und sie
spielt die Chefin der zombiepiratinnen
das Stück hat sie selbst geschrieben na
klar sie hat neben der Führungsposition
auch noch Kinder bestimmt bügelt der
Mann auch ihre Blusen was kommt denn
jetzt als nächstes
meinzelmädchen ja schön wär es hätten
die bloß nicht Mona Lisa abgesetzt
was Mona
Lisa
[Musik]
is okay ich muss jetzt
echt guten Abend na so langsam wird's
doch war ja auch ein langer Weg oh Mist
die
[Musik]
Theateraufführung